it's luis garcia on the mound for the
astros today certainly quite the
challenge for garcia going up against
this dodgers lineup leading things off
will be mookie betts for the dodgers
here comes the 1-2
swing and a miss got him on the good
cutter
down and away and that is out number one
meanwhile trevor bauer on the mound for
the dodgers the reigning national league
cy young award winner and he has
dominated the astros in his career they
haven't seen him in a little while
he's kind of got some personality and
some
some stuff out there that he doesn't
really like the houston astros
we were talking about trevor bauer's
history against the astros he's been
very good against him ever suffering a
loss this is his first start against him
since
the
sign stealing story broke officially
jose altuve starts it off batting 306
356 on base percentage five homers 19
rbis for altuve
altuve drives one deep to left field
homerun altuve
he jump starts this game for the astros
with a leadoff home run against their
nemesis trevor bauer it's one nothing
astros sixth home run of the season for
jose
and the astros take the lead early his
17th career lead off homer the third
that he's hit this year
well it's taylor jones who is a late
addition to the lineup this is just his
12th game in the big leagues but with
eurodon alvarez getting scratched a few
minutes before first pitch for the
saurus jones gets a rare start
the pitch to jones
swung on and missed strike three a
fastball with vengeance at 97.
bauer is torqued
but fortunate he's trailing only one to
nothing after one
one gone for the nine hitter maldonado
bauer on two and two maldonado
swings and misses down on strikes 95
mile an hour fastball that's the second
strikeout of the game for bauer and the
second out of the second
it'll be matt beatty their first baseman
for the dodgers leading things off
one ball and two strikes here's the
pitch got him swinging went after a high
fastball and garcia picks up his second
punch out and there's one away
two homers for noisy a 180 average he's
playing third base tonight right-handed
batter
here's the 3-2 got him swinging strike
three another fastball slipped it by him
and that's the third strikeout for luis
garcia and there's two away
here's mookie betts
punches the soft bouncer he gets under
garcia and allows bats to reach base
so the dodgers catching a break here
with two gone in the third so tsugo into
scoring position
and mookie aboard
sugo leading off second bets off first
muncie flied to center in his first
at-bat shift is on on the right side of
the infield deuces wild two on two out
in a 2-2 pitch
max muncie
pulls a line drag base hit into right
field tucker up with it tsutsugo headed
home the throw is up the line and the
dodgers tie the game
on a two-out rbi single from max muncie
and that'll load the bases for will
smith their cleanup man
here's the one-two
breaking ball got him strike three
went after a high slider
smith goes down and strands the bases
loaded
will go to the bottom of the third
inning as the dodgers won and the astros
won
two out julie gurial coming up
a 1-1 tie in the bottom of the third
gurial
pops it up into short left gavin lux is
out
makes the call in the catch and the
inning is over
no runs no hits one left after three the
dodgers and astros are tied at one
taylor the center fielder he grounded
out to third his last time up
swing and a miss taylor goes down that's
two outs
fifth strikeout for garcia two out to
the fourth here's taylor jones the dh he
struck out his last time up just got
called up
recently
he gets jones swinging with a high fast
ball
two up and two down here in the fourth
and we go to the fifth inning knotted at
one luis garcia 81 pitches
will face yossi satsugo to start
the otis atsugo
swing and a miss chase the breaking ball
gets between the legs of maldonado he'll
pick it up and throw to first
and that is out number one sixth
strikeout for garcia only one about five
feet behind martine so one out nobody on
for sheldon noisy he struck out in the
third
the kick in the 2-2
swing and a miss got him on a high
fastball seven strikeouts for garcia two
out
brings up carlos correa who was walked
and bounced back to bauer 2-0 and correa
lines it deep to left and that one is
into the landry's crawford boxes a home
run for correa and the astros have a 2-1
lead
correa homers for the seventh time this
year
i think correa was setting on the
breaking ball got the slider and hooked
it into the seats
there's maldonado
maldonado is struck out and lined out to
the left
oh one it's a one hopper to the
shortstop lux he's got it spins throws
high and maldonado reaches
pujols tried to come down with it and it
goes into the astros dugout
an error on lux
and the astros have a man in scoring
position
so altuve to the plate now with
maldonado on second
here's the 2-2
dribbler right side and that's through
they're going to send maldonado here's
the throw from betts and it is past the
catcher maldonado scores it's 3-1
so diaz at the plate now with altuve on
second
astros up three to one
first pitch from jones is ripped
left field out of here
diaz goes deep it's a two-run job
and it's five to one alexis diaz
a two run home run
and the astros jumping in front now five
to one
sheldon noisy now coming up
this ball well left center field back
towards the wall and gone
sheldon noisy with a home run his third
with the dodgers and it's 5-2
sheldon noisy got it all
his third home run
it is five to two
here's muncie he had an rbi single in
the third
2-1
ground ball up the middle diving bregman
field to chess in front of second gets
up and throws out muncie
outstanding play by bregman so two out
first and third
martine maldonado got aboard on a
throwing error by lux
in the seventh inning and it would prove
to be a costly miscue
no balls and a strike to martine
maldonado
who grounds it slowly to short
lux goes to first and that will end the
end
and now the dodgers are going to bring
pool holes to the plate as the tying run
2-2
swing and a miss struck him out on a
slider inside pujols goes down and so do
the dodgers as the houston astros win it
by a final of 5-2